I think any gynecologist will tell you
that it's an ovary and ovarian cancer
we're kind of at a loss really the only
thing we have to rely on is our patient
symptoms and being vigilant in our
annual exams there's no real good test
out there ca125 which is a blood test
which there's an email going around for
years now that it's a great cancer
screener it's almost like a PSA test for
four women and the same as the PSA is
for men and it really hasn't shown to be
that in fact there's a lot of false
positives to it so you end up kind of
chasing a lot of lab results and coming
up with nothing and creating a lot of
anxiety for patients so we really don't
have anything that we can offer as good
screening so basically just having a
high vigilance is all we can offer right
now but I think being on the birth
control pill is the best thing you could
do as far as prevention over the course
of two years
well I think it will help you know in
counseling our patients regarding
diseases they might anticipate when they
have children I think like any
technology it's always going to be far
ahead of our ability to deal with it you
know as anything the nuclear power or
whatever what have you we always seem to
be able to do stuff before we really
know how to ethically and morally deal
with it so I think the biggest play is
going to be on predicting cancers in
women with the BRCA gene which we have
already for the breast my hope is that
we'll see that you know for the ovary
that's probably something that's not as
far down the road
well partly because the ovaries are well
protected inside the mcdonald cavity of
a woman so a cancerous lesion basically
what they do or cells that grow and
don't recognize their neighbors so they
pile up on each other and they grow
rapidly they're allowed to grow and they
have the open kind of relative open in
space of the abdominal cavity in which
to grow so women won't feel too much
initially and it's only when the cancer
gets to a very large state where they
start to feel symptoms of other organs
being compressed and things like that so
that's why it's so so sinister there's
there's nothing obvious like a melanoma
you kind of see it and it grows and he
changes so you pick those up early the
uterus uterine cancer sends you a
literal red flag you know after the
menopause if a woman sees bleeding
that's a sign that there's something
wrong and uterine cancer is often picked
up early and cured because we have a
warning so the ovaries don't give us
much in the way of warning so bloating
is really the the one symptom that we
hear from patients that we always
respect and of course most times when
you work uploading you come up
empty-handed but we always have in the
back of our mind
dismal for ovarian cancer you know stage
three and four very low survival rate
although has improved in the last few
years with new chemotherapy regimens you
have a much better survival rate and you
know stage one cancer obviously but very
few were picked up majority of them
you
me